Odin one of the most predominant figures
in Norse mythology in nearly all
depictions of the God he's shown to only
have one eye but what is the story
behind Odin missing hi Odin's quest for
knowledge had taken him to the egg
Drusilla otherwise known as the world
tree located deep down underneath the
roots of the tree was Minnie as well
once Odin had arrived he asked me me if
he could drink from the water of the
well at first me merely declined telling
Odin that those who seek the knowledge
of the water must pay a great price
meeow meeow tells odin that many have
come in search for this knowledge but
once they learn of the price they must
pay no one pays Odin dared to ask me me
and found the price of such knowledge
was indeed his eye after a short period
of contemplation Odin accepted mamiya's
terms
Mamiya took his great horn and filled it
with water from the well
Odin began to drink and the future
became clear to him he saw all the
hardships that both men and gods would
have to face once he was finished
drinking odin reached for his face and
plucked from it he's right I owed and
then handed the item Amir who in turn
dropped it into the well the eye
remained in the water shining as a sign
to all who came the price that Odin the
father of gods paid for his wisdom Odin
has shown his willingness to harm
himself in order to gain knowledge on
several occasions as well as losing his
right eye he has starved himself stabbed
himself of his own spirit and even hung
himself for several days while he was on
his quest to discover the runes for me
this shows how much Odin values
knowledge there is no sacrifice too
great for wisdom if you've enjoyed this
video then please consider leaving it a
like as it helps a lot if there's
anything you'd like to discuss or topics
you'd like me to go over then please let
me know in the comments below until then
I'll see you guys in the next video